I have a question I have a question if I
said you guys look like lizzo would you
take it as a compliment s
her face and her confidence and the way
that she carries herself hell yeah
I can find beauty in every single woman
though like that
I think what Pearl is trying to get is
that it's okay to be normal it's okay
not to be a 10 out of 10 in society's
standards everybody is told nowadays
that they're special and that you're
attend yours and no let's be for real we
have to be honest with ourselves we go
out into the world I'm gonna go out
somewhere somebody's online black girls
guess what I'm gonna have to do except
that people don't like black girls I'm
gonna go out there and change the
world's opinion